bonjour aujourd'hui je vais vous parler
de le truc que j'aimerais voir beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus dans les débats
s'il ya un truc que j'aimerais voir
beaucoup beaucoup plus est dès à présent
partout sur twitter dans les
commentaires de cette vidéo ce sont les
marqueurs de modestie épistémique des
phrases du genre il me semble que des
phrases au conditionnel
des phrases comme j'aurais tendance à
dire que des phrases comme des petites
expressions comme peut-être probablement
sans doute les expressions comme si je
devais parier je dirais que des phrases
comme si on veut mais peut-être un
pistolet sur la tempe je parierais que
les manières de se distancier notre
propre intuition en disant par exemple
mon intuition on dirait que donnera
l'impression que c'est mon intuition est
que je suis totalement prêt à changer
d'avis ou encore des phrases et ça c'est
ma préférée j'aimerais vraiment l'avoir
beaucoup plus mais des phrases du genre
je me trompe sans doute mais il me
semble que ça c'est genre de phrase que
j'aimerais voir beaucoup beaucoup plus
dans toutes sortes de débats en
particulier ça me semble cruciale
utiliser tout ça pour bien distinguer
les différents 9° de crédence que l'on a
en différentes choses que l'on dit parce
que souvent on va s'exprimer sur
différents sujets et souvent on n'a pas
le même degré de créances sur tous les
sujets en tout cas il semble adéquat de
faire la distinction notamment pour que
sur des sujets où à notre propre avis
paraît peut être pertinent mais on n'a
pas envie que ça soit confus une
confusion entre ce qu'on dit juste là
est ce qu'on dirait sur le théorème de
pythagore ou sur des théorèmes
mathématiques pour vraiment faire cette
distinction et pour que les gens savent
à quel point les choses que l'on dit
sont fiables
est-ce qu'on s'appuie ce juste sur une
étude récente ou est-ce qu'on s'appuie
sur tout un corpus scientifique et abby
et qu'un consensus scientifique très
fort derrière et reconnus par la
communauté scientifique depuis des des
centaines d'années toutes ces choses
devraient être exposés de manière
différente et pour y arriver il me
semble vraiment indispensable et
j'aimerais vraiment voir ça beaucoup
plus que l'on prenne l'habitude de
distinguer différents noeuds degré de
crédence que l'on a en différentes
différentes choses que l'on croit et
pour cela est vraiment ces marqueurs de
moi des steppes estime qu'ils sont très
très très important vous invite vraiment
à les utiliser et à bien les utiliser
je veux dire qu'il s'agit pas d utiliser
pour paraître modeste un mythe la
modestie
voilà c'est pas du tout l'objectif en
tout cas du tiff c'est vraiment
d'améliorer la communication et la
réflexion collective et pour cela il me
semble indispensable que chacun d'entre
nous passions l'effort de préciser le
degré de créances que l'on a on a
chacune des choses que l'on dit et pour
y arriver encore il faut utiliser ces
marqueurs de modestie épistémique et
utiliser celui qui est adéquat par
rapport à tel ou tel de la situation par
exemple dire je parie sans flipper que
où il me semble extrêmement probable que
ça m'étonnerait énormément que ça c'est
des façons d'exprimer un avis très très
très prononcé et peut-être que sur
d'autres avis ce sera beaucoup plus en
mode je me trompe peut-être mais il me
semble que ou encore je ne suis
absolument pas expert mais j'aurais dit
que blablabla
et donc là je voudrais vous parler d'un
peu de la version honnête de choses mais
je pense qu'il ya la version un peu plus
manipulatrice que j'aurais tendance à
encourager à utiliser également qui est
simplement une stratégie de
communication de se mettre en arrière et
de mettre les autres en avant et de
d'utiliser marqueur de modestie
épistémique non pas pour montrer notre
incertitudes épistémique mais peut-être
davantage pour soulever des questions
soulevées des suggestions et aussi pour
normaliser une certaine forme de
modestie épistémique qui me semble est
extrêmement déficiente très souvent dans
les débats surtout dans des débats les
avis sont très prononcé typiquement dès
que ça à voir avec la politique ou les
sujets de société
donc là je vais parler de stratégie de
communication vers les autres une
certaine manière mais également une
stratégie de communication envers nous
mêmes parce que bah on est des êtres
très très très faillible psychologie de
l'humain est ce qu'elle est si vous
croyez au delà de la psychologie
rencontres et vivement les nombreuses
vidéos de sens quand yves que ce soit
celle du gène mental de ta vie doit
penser que nantes ou les vidéos de la
tranche
biais ou absolue une belle série de
vidéos sur le sujet je recommande
vivement de regarder ces vidéos pour
sentir que votre propre psychologie et
probablement très très défaillante tout
comme la mienne on a tous des
psychologies d'humains qui vous était
pas du tout sélectionnés pour leur
capacité à bien réfléchir est absolument
crucial de prendre ça en compte lorsque
l'on réfléchit et c'est pour ça que
c'est très utile d'avoir ces marqueurs
de modestie épistémique parce que
malheureusement on a tendance à oublier
les failles potentielles de nos
raisonnements et avoir le réflexe de
rajouter ces marqueurs de me tester
épistémique même quand on n'y croit pas
ça peut nous amener à nous auto nos
jeans certaine manière nous forcer à
remettre un peu plus en question ce
qu'on fait nous a tendance à encourager
ces marqueurs de modestie épistémique
même si vous n'y croyez pas parce que
c'est une façon de s'auto même manipulé
d'une façon de faire en sorte que la
partie qui en excès de confiance en nous
perde un peu de son excès de confiance
et que l'on se mette davantage à
réfléchir à pourquoi est ce que l'on
pense ce qu'on pense et qu'on se mette
dans une situation où on sera plus
facilement prêt à changer d'avis parce
que bon si on dit john seront sans doute
mais il me semble que blablabla ce sera
beaucoup plus facile de les changer
d'avis ensuite sur bla bla bla que si on
avait dit je pense que blablabla
là on sent que le bla bla bla et
beaucoup plus attachés votre
personnalité et ce sera plus difficile
de changer d'avis donc parlant de
laisser revenir c'est un réflexe
apprendre ça réflexe que j'ai
l'impression d'avoir appris petit à
petit à utiliser j'ai l'impression que
ça me fait du bien sera que ça m'arrive
souvent d'écrire intuit et de dirhams 1
qui n'ont ciapa de marqueurs modolo de
seuil épidémique dans ce tweet et juste
avant de publier je me dis bon bah je
vais rajouter le marqueur de modestie
épistémique ça paraît tout bête et après
je suis quand même beaucoup plus content
de mon tweet est également je sens que
ça m'a fait réfléchir
ça m'a permis de me rendre compte qu'en
fait j'étais en excès de confiance
je pense que c'est vraiment un truc qui
marche vraiment bien en tout cas je vous
encourage vraiment au moins à essayer
pendant un petit bout de temps au moins
prochains mois essayait de faire en
sorte que les prochains mois partout à
chaque fois vous crise écrire un message
sur un réseau social ou si possible dans
la discussion aussi
en vrai irl essayé d'utiliser ces
marqueurs de modestie épistémique
essayer de réfléchir à comment est ce
que ça change aux réflexions je pense
que c'est un exercice absolument
fascinant tout cas je l'encouragé très
vivement et d'une serre venir j'aimerais
vraiment le voir être appliquée on va
vraiment voir une évolution donc si vous
êtes sur twitter ou dans les
commentaires de cette vidéo je veux voir
des mots dit mme parker dont medelci
épistémique même si c'est juste pour
faire semblant
j'aimerais vraiment voir si les
marqueurs de modestie systémique je
pense que on a beaucoup à y gagner
allez voir davantage normalisée